I'm the best you are obviously not the
best when I some was like I was seeing
her ghost like every trigger I've ever
pulled
how'd he start you hunting birds rabbit
guessing 19 20 years old the first time
he ordered you to shoot a person
25 years ago he took my blood
made you from me
has been lying to you the whole time
told you you were an orphan and all the
people in the world to come after me why
would he send you
because I'm the best you are obviously
not the best and just trying to rattle
me trying to save you you made a choice
to do this to me
the whole point of this thing was to
give you all of Henry's gifts without
his pain I don't want to shoot you mind
if I shoot you
Henry is this ever having you before
your own government trying to kill you
Wow that's new
everything that we've worked for is at
stake
[Music]
he has to die he's your darkness you had
to walk through this on your own I love
you Junior
look what we created
you're the inspiration for all of us why
not just make a whole army full of it
why not you should be flattered you
should be dead
this has to be stopped
because what if somebody actually know
what we really are
you